c'était super spectacle il y avait
beaucoup numéro très différent il y
avait beaucoup de haut niveau
franchement entre acrobates dresseurs de
chiens clown magicien le 19e festival
international des mureaux c'était le
grand retour du cirque une réussite pour
le public comme pour les jurys cette
année on a un niveau vraiment très élevé
on a de jeunes et de beaux numéros qui
sont un petit peu des découvertes aussi
de ce festival on a vraiment des numéros
un petit peu confirmé qu'ils viennent
vraiment appuyer une programmation de
choix et voilà on est très fiers de
pouvoir à nouveau se produire bien
évidemment sur la piste 10 numéros ont
été présentés par des artistes de tous
les horizons c'est un numéro de mât
chinois c'est un poteau qui fait 6
mètres de haut c'est une discipline
asiatique est
la figure emblématique c'est l'homme
drapeau est donc bénéfique aussi la
femme drapeau mais c'est aussi surtout
notre histoire d'amour qu'on raconte
autour de cette discipline très physique
un retour en piste synonyme de
retrouvailles avec les chapiteaux c'est
un peu stressant
en même temps c'est excitant c'est un
chapiteau magnifique et le public est
incroyable il nous donne tellement
d'énergie un festival tremplin pour les
artistes en cas de bonnes appréciations
ils présenteront leurs numéros à travers
le monde on a utilisé la période du
corona pour créer un nouveau numéro de
trapèze un peu modifié avec des nouveaux
costumes des nouvelles musiques ce
festival est un bon endroit pour
présenter ce numéro au monde du cirque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
deux jours de festival ponctué par une
remise des prix le dimanche après-midi
un premier prix décerné aux jo bazzali
pour leur numéro de trapèze quant au
français du duo frénésie une première
place également avec le prix spécial du
jury